back in 2014 big hero six fast forwarded
us to the year of 2150 to see a world
where science is practically magic
between honey lemons chem lab in a purse
able to summon every element on the
periodic table to mongos electromagnetic
rollerblades and baymax's cutting-edge
diagnostic technology any way you slice
it Disney's vision of the future is
filled with technological fantasies
beyond our wildest imagination which
makes it all the more mind-blowing to be
that 136 years later amidst it all we're
still using iPhones
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
just as squishy as baymax not nearly as
useful however so the other day I was
binge buying a bunch of Disney movies on
Google Play since Disney is launching
their own Netflix style subscription
service next year and I expect them to
make all of their movies impossible to
buy in order to force everyone to
subscribe to this thing and I just can't
handle another subscription service in
my life why can't I just own the things
I'm paying for whoo millennial angst
talking and already movies like
Cinderella Little Mermaid and Aladdin
aren't available which is just sad
anyway as I was saying this binge
session got me to revisit a bunch of
Disney movies that I kind of overlooked
or skimmed over the first time that I
watched them and one such movie was big
hero 6 and you know what stood out not
just the impressive futuristic
technology the sheer volume and variety
of it in this movie an inflatable
medical robot plasma weaponry a deadly
sign-spinning exosuit but by far the
most incredible thing or things that we
see in the movie are these the microbots
our main character Hiro that's Hiro with
an H iro not to be confused with big
hero 6 h er o of the movie's title
invents these deceptively simple robots
that when their powers combined can
practically do it all the technology is
so innovative that it does the
impossible it impresses everyone at the
science fair
which let's be honest it's the science
fair anything that goes beyond I dropped
teeth and soda and made him dissolve is
gonna be impressive let alone I invented
a technology that will revolutionize
robotics these microbots catch the eye
of our villain who looks like he was
ripped straight out of fortnight season
5 and he ends up stealing the technology
to achieve number one victory royale
anyway all of it got me wondering could
a technology like this actually work
will I sometime in the next hundred and
thirty six years be able to control a
swarm of microbots using only my mind to
I don't know do whatever micro robots
controlled by your mind with you make a
smoothie film theorists start warming up
those trifle boards now because today
we're looking at heroes winning science
fair project and teaching you how to
steal what he did to get yourself an
a-plus oh yeah
I changed the history of modern robotics
anything else
wait Hiro introduces these things in the
movie make him seem like he's a
reincarnated Steve Jobs showing us the
iPhone 70 now with even fewer features
and faster planned obsolescence
but looking past hero's height what
exactly would it take to invent the
microbots that we see in the movie I
think you could break it down into three
clear components one the microbots are
small and are all capable of moving
independently to the mic robots are
capable of moving in a coordinated
manner with hundreds or even thousands
of them acting together in response to a
single command and last of all this
one's the doozy number three the
microbots are controlled by the users
mind via a neural interface think it and
it happens the microbots are controlled
with this neurotransmitter
I think what I want them to do they do
it and we have to do all of that within
the next hundred and thirty six years
think it can be done place your bets now
in the comments and then re-watch this
video and twenty one fifty and tell me
if you are right I'll just be hanging
out in my stasis pod waiting to be
revitalized by then so you know I'll be
looking for a bit of excitement first
the size the microbots are as you might
guess from the name individually very
small looking less than an inch long and
as it turns out this is entirely
possible not just in the future but
today right now 2018 as you are watching
this video in fact real-world robotics
actually get a lot smaller than what
Hiro showing as far back as 2005
scientists were creating robots that
were literally named micro robots
because they were only 60 micrometers
wide and 200 50 micrometers long so tiny
that you'd need a microscope to actually
see them moving a hero if your robots
aren't small enough for their lengths to
be measured in micrometers maybe you
should consider giving them a different
name like Milla BOTS or senti bots it's
not quite as catchy but it is certainly
more accurate truth in advertising my
friend now granted these real-world
micro robots are a far cry from the
micro robots that we see in the movie
these 60 micrometer robots can move
along like an inchworm but they're not
useful for all that much so a better
question would be could you actually
make a useful robot as small as the
microbots in big hero 6 the answer is
yet again a surprising yes in 2015
scientists at Harvard unveiled the Robo
be a drone whose body is shorter than
the diameter of a penny
unlike the micro robots which seemed
like more of an experiment to simply see
how small they could make the tech the
Robo bees are actually small for a
specific reason a small size lets them
fly more easily and they're so light
that they can cling to surfaces like an
actual bee wood using static electricity
it also has the really nifty function of
carrying a tiny camera which means that
it has real-world applications is the
world's smallest spy drone think about
that the next time you feel an insect
landing on your neck maybe it's not some
angry Hornet coming to plant a stinger
in your flesh maybe it's just some
foreign government who wants to really
close-up photos of the inside of your
ear suffice it to say size-wise Hiro's
microbots go solidly in the territory of
not only possible in the year 2115 but
actually already done in the Year 2015
okay so it's one thing to make a robot
small but it's entirely another thing to
have an entire swarm of robots that are
all able to move together and this isn't
just as simple as have a bunch of micro
robots and tell them all to do the same
thing when Hiro's microbots form into
the hand and wave at the audience think
about how hard that action is some of
the bots have to serve as the wrist
while others have to form the joints of
the individual fingers each one of those
has to know its position to serve that
function and then on top of it all they
all have to move in conjunction with all
the other micro robots to get into that
specific position and then execute its
function in tandem with everyone else
and yet for as difficult as it may be
looking at the research we once again
learned that this isn't simply the stuff
of science fiction Hiro's microbots
combine two fields of study swarm
robotics where a bunch of separate
smaller robots work together and modular
design the idea of taking a small number
of modules that can then be combined and
recombined in a variety of shapes and
configurations for an example of a
self-configuring robot see the rebus
reconfigurable bipedal snake which is
capable of moving as a two-legged biped
walker like a human while also having
the ability to move around on the ground
like a snake or if you're in the mood
for a larger swarm of robots all working
together well look no further than
Harvard yet again where their robotics
teams have also managed to create a
thousand robot swarm capable of
assembling itself into various shapes
sure it's nothing nearly as complex as
Hiro's microbots swarm yes we're the
total number of microbots is closer to
millions not thousands but we're on the
right track and the idea of catching up
to Hiro's microbots by the year twenty
one fifty seems easy when you consider
how far along these two fields are so in
terms of size and coordinated movement
Hiro's microbots look not only
realistically attainable but even
currently possible however there's one
huge part of big hero six is tag that
seems to stretch the limits of
believability the neural transmitter the
microbots are controlled with this
neurotransmitter
I think what I want them to do they do
it this feels like part of the movie
where things move out of science-fiction
and into the realm of fantasy at least
that's what you might be thinking but
not only her neural interface is a real
field of study it's a field of study
that has shown some real results
surprisingly enough the idea of creating
machines capable of reading and reacting
to human thought is pretty old dating
all the way back to the 1970s one
specific case that we know about comes
from a 1975 report titled feasibility
study for design of a bio cybernetic
communication system which is based on
the findings of a three year study
conducted by the Stanford Research
Institute and funded by DARPA which I'm
sure you've heard of at some point in a
Marvel movie or on TV basically it
stands for Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency and is an agency of the
United States Department of Defense
responsible for development of emerging
technologies that military uses and yes
if you're wondering it is always
military defense spending that gives us
these weird fringe Sciences that push
the limits of what's possible this was
especially true when you had an entire
country willing to do whatever it took
to outwit the Soviets in the Cold War
anyway the purpose of the study was
quote to test the feasibility of
designing a close coupled two-way
communication link between man and
computer using biological information
from muscles of the vocal apparatus and
the electrical activity of the brain
during overt and covert speech end quote
so to break that down into ordinary
English the thinking is that our brain
has two ways of delivering words overt
speech speaking out loud and covert
speech which is thinking to yourself the
idea is that even when you're not
opening your mouth to say words simply
thinking a sentence to yourself will
activate the parts of your brain that
processed speech and language just as if
you had actually opened your mouth and
Scobie those words aloud and these brain
signals can then be read and translated
and acted upon by a machine
in short you could think thoughts to a
computer instead of saying them out loud
and they weren't wrong in their thinking
around this the study found that the
electroencephalograph ii readouts
EEG readouts which measure electrical
impulses in different parts of the brain
for overt speech actually matched up
with the ones for covert speech now
granted the results were far from
perfect one source of error was that if
subjects were distracted or had a
twitchy eye the signals from the brain
telling the eyes to move would interfere
with the signals for the speech but
according to the report once you
accounted for those errors to match
between what the Machine readout and
what people were actually thinking
ranged from 52% to 72% well those
numbers might not sound all that high
but think about what that's saying
you've got what is essentially a
mind-reading robot that's as much as 72
percent accurate that is pretty darn
impressive and that was way back in the
1970s and in case you needed any more
evidence that heroes dream of neuro BOTS
that can react to your thoughts might
one day be a reality see this headline
from September of 2018 yeah the year
that we are currently in and a month ago
stating that it's now possible to
telepathically communicate with a drone
swarm now there are a lot of caveats
here the main one being that it's done
via a chip that has to be surgically
implanted into the brain this isn't just
some headband that you're gonna slap on
your forehead and take off at will but
if you're the kind of person who's into
getting invasive brain surgery so you
can show off your latest tech gadget
well the future is now friends although
you might not want to hop on that boat
too soon we all know what happened to
Google glass in all seriousness though
most of the people who've been test
subjects for this technology are people
who are already having brain operations
to help solve neurological issues like
epilepsy and early results are
shockingly positive how cool is it that
even the most fantastical seeming
technology that we see in big hero 6 is
actually feasible not just in a hundred
years not just in 50 years but right now
today we're already there when it comes
to size engineering swarm robots as
quickly scaling up and with the right
equipment you can even control drones
with your mind right now even though
film theory is usually in the business
of ruining your childhood or honestly
just your favorite movies since big hero
6 is only four years old at this point
that's not the case today I am here to
make your favorite movies come true well
except for the fact that heroes device
here is impressive to everyone but he's
simply just ripping off technology that
exists today
a hundred years prior to the events of
that movie oh and the fact that the
microbots managed to perform amazing
feats of strength without ever being at
risk of draining the teeny tiny
batteries that they run on in a film
where it's established that's simply
waddling around San fransokyo for a day
is enough to drain baymax's battery to
practically zero
microbots mind control no problem
effective batteries now that is crazy
talk but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and if you want to see more about
how modular robotics technology is
making transformers into a reality
well then neurologically move your mouse
over to the left and click the box or
alternatively if you want to see me ruin
another of your favorite disney movies
that's the box to the right and make
sure you subscribe because we've been
hovering just under 7 million
subscribers for a long time now and it
would be so sweet to get 7 million
subscribers on this channel before the
end of the year thank you guys so much
for watching I'll see you for something
a bit scarier in a bit more Halloweeny
next week